hey guys i'm ryan right i'm dan Seibert
we're gonna watch the trailer today for
Borderlands the pre-sequel moon dance
trailer I don't know anything about
Borderlands actually which is gonna piss
a lot of you off automatically I love me
some boredom ants can you just give me a
basic rundown of a board lenses oh Jesus
oh so I can uh basically well okay this
is gonna be slightly different but in my
one and two you play as vault hunters
who are seeking these vaults that are
supposed to be full of loot the first
one the stories kind of find this vault
do all this stuff a little more serious
but the second one there's this main
villain called handsome jack who you
need to take down who is a total [ __ ]
but a very [ __ ] funny [ __ ] but
he's a dick this game the trailer we're
about to watch is for the game that
happens between Borderlands 1 and
Borderlands 2 that's how it's a pre
sequel I love it it's so clever
Webber that's clever or else watch it
that's it
god
haha
goddammit this guy's nothing like a fun
trailer
ah
for that
okay it's just a trailer alone yeah just
a trailer I was [ __ ] brilliant
regular it's a great trailer alone yeah
god they do such a good job there their
trailer for Borderlands 2 was very
similar to this where it's just like
dubstep like I forgot the most important
thing about Borderlands what I was
telling you about him it's that no gun
is the same oh they're like crazy like
algorithm that just like spits out
[ __ ] weird awesome guns cool cool
yeah no it looks like a looks like
exactly what I could get into surprise
and never seen footage of this game
before it's so much fun I love more
Lance dude yeah Alex every once in a
while there's a game fear that comes
along I'm like that looks cool but then
this one was like I could definitely
play this game oh yeah
dude I'm like a ton of fun you got the
360 I'll let you borrow the first two oh
really yeah you should you would do that
I'm do that for you bro dude does a long
camera thing like you mean that well
when we turn this off I'll slap you and
then I'll give them to you it's worth it
mmm I gained slept you just do it it's
our thing thanks for recommending that
trailer if you're new to the channel you
can subscribe to the real rejects
and dan has a gaming channel you could
subscribe to his channel that's cyber
channel it's fun stuff fun stuff happens
there seriously
I play games and then I get mad at them
and he uploads weekly mm-hmm upload on
the rig that's right
Zach Hale hey buddy sure I've been
loving your videos ever since I
subscribed I wish I had subscribed
earlier for a while the only people I
watched on YouTube was roster teeth and
I Rossiter teeth roosterteeth sorry I
only have one
rooster teeth and I refuse to watch
anyone else because I just never liked
any my youtuber any youtuber the way I
like the people of roosterteeth but when
I first saw one of your videos I felt
some sort of connection like yeah these
people are actually kind of cool and
funny and aren't overdoing it no we
don't overdo it here haha oh yeah I'm
connecting you guys just seemed like
someone I could relate to and I would
love to meet you all someday but I leave
for boot camp in the US Navy in 14 days
August 13th oh we're really late on you
no no and it would be amazing if you
gave me a shout-out before I left and
wish me luck it's going to suck the
Africa a few months without seeing your
videos but after training all binge
watch all the ones I missed oh no how do
we how do we have to get this design we
have to get it to him we have to find
out where he is keep up the excellent
work have a good one okay Zach Hale um
that was like one of the most flattering
comments ever which led to me feeling
like one of the biggest douchebags ever
I don't know how this isn't a lie how
did I miss this
I don't know [ __ ] damn everyone we need
to get this video to Zach Hale whatever
you do let go comment on his channel or
whatever post the link to this get this
- Zach Hale I just feel like a dick
because he's like doing something
serviceable Shh we'll get it to him we
got this okay we got this okay [ __ ] that
psycho reviewer oh hey can you make a
shout-out to my channel that psycho
reviewer shout-out to that psycho
reviewer that psycho reviewer dude I
know so much about your channel it's
ridiculous just how much information I
know but your channel I just he does
reviews kind of with crazy eccentric
energy I have that cyber channel and
I've definitely seen that one too
I watch your videos but do you have that
in your channel name know that real
rejects that's why I should call it
don't just about me a some manish AC
Manish yo Ryan right give me a shout-out
please and if you do give me
please link me Wow you're lucky you got
a hat Veronica now this might sound
inappropriate and creepy but how is she
in the bed my friend before you say
anything I am I you are in a very
delicate situation yes do you want to
get some ever again or do you want to
not get some ever again
I I want to get some ever again I want
to keep her as my girlfriend so I can't
answer that question because now it's
about to be it's about the team yeah
before it it's just me I could say
whatever the [ __ ] I wanted and now it's
like I'm when it comes to her
specifically it's just about me as
everyone look up to her specifically I
can't say I just can't say this is the
most mature I have ever seen you ever
I'm I am really trying I'm proud as hell
right you know how hard it is to not
just answer a question I know you want
to do that I rather just say yeah she's
the bomb ever but I don't do that damn
it you just did it
no I'm saying I'd rather say hey hey
we'll leave it with this have you ever
had a toaster strudel yes totally
irrelevant to like anything that's
happening but those rules are delicious
you should end on that home